do you think government has always been
this overtly corrupt or are we just
finally seeing it because of access to
information i actually think this is the
most annoying time to be a corrupt
government official because social media
is the ultimate
great equalizer so if they control
the great equalizer which is social
media why do you think so many people
out of nowhere started saying how much
they hate facebook
i'm sorry why do you hate facebook
why do you hate facebook okay so
take twitter out does trump get elected
no if twitter is not started your
president is today
your president today is hillary clinton
absolutely if jack dorsey and those guys
don't start today to twitter president
it's hillary clinton today she gave a
great speech or pictures on a wall right
and she unfortunately she would have not
had the master class which is a shame
because that master class on how to
handle the laws would have never been
there right in that newsweek magazine
would have never been there because that
newsweek magazine would have been
official so mckinnon with that's a great
snl opening so i think i think all of
these uh
government officials who were able to
play the games back in the days like
what he's from you know what you're
showing right now with uh what do you
call it the um
yeah uh uh is
what's that 50 years ago what's that a
hundred years ago was it
you show this right now a person who's
extremely interested in this guess
what's the first thing they're doing
what are you talking about i'm going to
google it back then you couldn't google
it right kennedy files they just buried
the kennedy files for all those years
roswell yeah so you know bob kirsten or
i will have he's a former chairman of
limbra
and uh he sits currently i think he as a
board member for
uh i think a
consultant for bain and he was a former
president with hartford back in the days
a credible guy lots
annual uh big board meeting that we have
and we're having conversations and
during lunch he says during dinner at
the dakotas he says how much do you read
like
every time i'm talking like how much do
you read are you always reading are you
always you know collecting data
and we're going through it and uh he
asked a question about this one guy they
used to be a big insurance trainer back
in the days and i google him and i say
tama this guy says yeah
and then 30 minutes later he says you
know when i was coming up in the game i
couldn't get an answer to any question
as quickly as you just got it the edge
your generation has over me is any
question can be answered like this i had
to go to the library to find the
articles that that guy wrote to find the
book access because i couldn't even get
the book you couldn't go find a book you
had to wait a few weeks to go find who
sells an older book of a guy today
so access to information
the speed of access to information has
both positive and negative the positive
the negative to me is
we get angrier faster
we have anxiety more than ever before
stress higher before
you know arguments are higher because i
want to fight you now back in the days i
had 30 minutes till i came home to fight
my wife today i can fight you right now
while i'm driving and texting and
calling it yeah so you're you're
literally never off the clock you're
never off the clock that that that is
like heroin man it's so addicting right
now they used to say the average person
touches this 150 times a day 150 times a
day
that's a couple thousand times
right
but the positive side of what this has
done
is these politicians these the
establishment they hate this yeah but
that doesn't stop them well yeah but
you know the scene where joe pastone got
all these mobsters arrested and they all
walked out and one by one by one by one
yeah
i don't know i think uh
you know a scene like that could be
happening very soon and it needs to
happen one time that's all needs to
happen yeah to set the tone publicly it
needs to happen one time needs to happen
one time all these guys talk about
when's the last time you saw you know a
person that's you know with money never
get arrested and all this other stuff
was the last time he said when's the
last time you saw politicians walking up
for manipulation behind closers and all
this other stuff i'm going to give
credit to aoc which is something i
rarely do you know what i usually said
the other day
she said i don't own any stock
why not she says i think it's not fair
for
people in office like myself
to own and invest in any stock because
we have more access to information than
the rest of you do that's a shot at
nancy pelosi that's a shot at manchester
united
and the best portfolio tracker exactly
the best portfolio tracker of all time
tick tockers follow what her husband
does next and boom 88 whatever the
number is unbelievable it's unbelievable
so
you know
you know there's people like that that
are going to annoy the hell out of the
establishment she's a socialist
economically we're completely on
opposite sides
but if there's one thing you may be on
the same side with her
she's anti-establishment
full-on anti-establishment so i i don't
think the days of playing politics and
games and all that stuff can you pull up
with elizabeth warren and elon musk just
went through did you see that twitter
award there that was great it was
beautiful man so elizabeth warren says
let's change the rigged tax code so the
person of the year will actually pay
taxes and stop freeloading off of
everyone else like she's trying to
get her audience that's not even the
best one he had two others
of it
you got to get the rest of it that's not
it and then you almost respond and says
please don't call the manager on me
senator karen yeah he's like yeah he's
like you're like that one lady that just
always gets mad at everybody she says
you're like one of my friends uh old
lady moms that would always angry yeah
that's right yeah the answer gerard like
to answer your question i think pat's
100 right i think the revolving door has
always been there but they've gotten to
the point where this is just blatant
yeah i mean this is so blatant but they
did not count on
the social media i wouldn't be sitting
here right now being interviewed by you
guys if it wasn't for twitter and it
wasn't for the social media the xrp army
utilizing it jay clayton you know we've
been hitting uh cnbc uh every day they
bring jay clayton on who is a
contributor to cnbc and they'll they ask
him a question and just says hey that
your critics say there's a conflict and
he goes i'm not going to comment and
then they brought him on to date again
and she goes listen everywhere i go it's
the same question you know are you going
to address the ethics issue and he goes
i'm not going to talk about pending
litigation there's no pitting litigation
about your ethics yeah right yeah like
we're questioning your integrity and you
won't defend yourself that doesn't sound
like you you were the former sec
chairman of the united states securities
exchange commission and you can't answer
a few questions but but this is kind of
where i'm going with that is like this
is what it half scares me and half
infuriates me i feel like you know
learning history from before i was alive
that at least these people had the the
good sense to try to hide their
corruption exactly there was a fear of
public retribution now we may not have
had access to the information but there
was a fear like oh my god these people
find out we're in big trouble that just
doesn't exist anymore i mean what
they're doing with with the you know
what the ftc is doing with the pfizer
shots and yeah we'll let you know what's
in them we'll let you know what we knew
in 55 years now it's 75 years
on its base point i mean that's just so
insulting it's so infuriating that you
you threatened people's livelihoods you
said you got to get this or you're not
going to be allowed to fly you're not
gonna you're we're gonna get you fired
from your job unless you get this thing
okay what's in it we'll tell you in 75
years what
like bro what like and it's not just
that it's over and over and over again
the overt corruption
that they just they do it and then they
move on and there's literally there's
this error of like yeah yeah we did it
what are you going to do about it how
many times has jp morgan and
goldman sachs been fined for
manipulating gold and silver markets
and it just keeps happening and
happening you know if you make a billion
you're willing to pay a hundred million
dollars yeah it's a good business model
and it absolutely is yeah so you know
the the inferior and i don't know is it
so is that on the public we have access
to this information but we don't hold
these people accountable is that on us
is this uh have we just has this
environment just created a new brand of
overtly corrupt politicians that just
don't care what the public thinks they
feel insulated from any sort of i mean
maxine waters literally told people to
go burn down american cities literally
did it's like get out there if you see
if you see people that you politically
disagree with in restaurants make it
hard on them you know that's terrorism
that's that's the literal definition of
terrorism well i mean using violence to
promote politics is the literal
definition of terrorism again that that
is why that is why the people want to
see an anti-establishment in the white
house
that's why half the country wants to see
an anti-establishment person in the
white house to see if they're going to
hold those people accountable that's the
biggest part look you know
they say yeah people get into politics
with the right intentions i'm going to
go
correct this injustice that's happening
and you're in it for a year three years
five years eight years a re-election is
coming up you need a favor you give this
guy the favor he gives you the money you
get re-elected now you're part of the
establishment now your crusade your
cause you were a true believer you're no
longer a statesman now you're officially
what you're part of the establishment
you're done and they're gonna hold you
to it for the rest of your life it's
game over with right okay
this is why uh a person that's coming
that's not part of the establishment
that annoys the hell out of everybody
is what america needs today because if
they talk about the stuff that these
guys don't they go to the same country
clubs they go to the same parties they
go ahead and get at the same time
fraternities in college you want to pull
out what musk said this is the whole
twitter says stop projecting you remind
me uh of uh when i was a kid and my
friend's angry mom would just randomly
yell out everyone for no reason please
don't call the manager on me senator
karen just look at her she looks like
she's not really that happy with her
life you know she looks bitter and
upset
doesn't pay taxes it's just like again
it it it's just such gaslighting it's
such nonsensical [ __ ]
how much do you think he pays payroll
taxes alone how many jobs have they got
so
yeah that's why i want to know how many
jobs have these these structure that
that yeah yeah yeah like what what have
they added well you know i i i can tell
you i live i grew up in detroit single
mother welfare food stamps growing up i
did not hate
the wealthier rich man i wanted to know
what he knew yeah what can you tell me
that i don't know so that i can do that
this class warfare
has just gotten out of hand you know
what i mean well they're doing it on
purpose it's like
can you imagine that we're going to only
tax unrealized gains of billionaires
unrealized gains
unrealized gains unrealized gains did
that come out of your mouth
that you're going to attack someone for
unrealized gains so so elon musk
detection on the money elon musk stock
price goes through the roof we're going
to tax him but then when it crashes when
there's a recall or something he can't
write it off so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]